T
IT.
>> DECEMBER 15th.
>> A LITTLE EARLY, RIGHT.
WHAT'S THE TRUTH ON WHERE AND
HOW THE VIRUS ORIGINATED.
WHY ARE OFFICIALS HERE AND IN
CHINA LYING ABOUT IT.
MIKE GALLAGHER HAS BEEN PUSHING
FOYER ANSWERS LIKE WE.
HAVE HE REPRESENTS THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN AND JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN GALLAGHER, WHAT DO
YOU TAKE FROM THE HUNDRED PAGE
REPORT?
>> TO ME IT CONFIRMS WHAT WE
HAVE KNOWN FOR MONTHS WHICH IS
THAT FAUCI LIED TO US.
LIED TO CONGRESS.
HE NOW THAT OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS
WERE BEING AN MINISTERED BY HIS
ORGANIZATION TO THIRD PARTIES TO
DO COOPERATIVE RESEARCH, GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH AT WUHAN.
WHEN QUESTIONED HE LIED AND RID
BEHIND A DEFINITION.
HE STILL HAS A JOB AND IN FRONT
OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS THAT HAVE SUFFERED AND
DIED TO CORONAVIRUS.
WE NOW HAVE THE 90-DAY
INTELLIGENCE REVIEW FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION COMING BACK
WITH NOTHING.
THAT'S UNEXSUSCEPTIBLE.
SAYING WE CAN'T GET TO THE
BOTTOM UNTIL WE HAVE THE
COOPERATION OF THE CHINESE.
THAT'S BOGUS.
START WITH SUBPOENAING PETER D.
AND HIS CORRUPT ORGANIZATION.
>> CONGRESSMAN, SENATOR JOSH
HOLLY IS DEMANDING FAUCI STEPS
DOWN.
ARE YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY AT A MINIMUM HE
SHOULD STEP DOWN.
WE SHOULD HAVE A FULL
TRANSPARENT INVESTIGATION TO
LOOK INTO THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
FUNDING THIS RESEARCH.
WHERE IS THE ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY?
WHY IS THIS ADMINISTRATION
COVERING UP WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS?
ARE WE SO AFRAID OF OFFENDING
THAT WE WON'T DEMAND ANSWERS
AFTER THEY HAVE PERP RATED ONE
OF THE BIGGEST COVERUPS IN
HISTORY.
THIS SUN ACCEPTABLE.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
THIS.
>> CONGRESSMAN, IF ANTHONY
FAUCI, IS SO VULNERABLE TO THIS
WHY IS HE ON EVERY TELEPHONE TEN
SHOW AND HE WAS ON CNN TODAY AND
NOT ASKED ABOUT THIS REPORT.
A REPORT IN THE INTERCEPT?
>> BECAUSE THE ENTIRE MEDIA HAS
GONE LOOK LINE AND SINKER FOR
THIS NARRATIVE.
THAT WAS PERPETRATED AS YOU
POINTED OUT IN YOUR MONOLOG.
WE HAD SCIENTISTS WITH PROFOUND
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST WRITING
LETTERS AND TELLING EVERYONE
THIS DIDN'T COME FROM A LAB.
THE MEDIA WENT FOR IT.
THEY'RE ACTING AS USEFUL IDIOTS
FOR THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
AND THEY'RE AFRAID TO ADMIT
THEY'RE WRONG.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME ON
THIS.
FAUCI H